hi guys TGIF someone's having fun
show them yes whip your toy back and
forth whip your toy back and boy it is
pride diary and let's see what the [ __ ]
happened this week I went did this it's
black Rupert Grint black Rupert Grint
did you see it
now here's my face they went to my
friend Sarah Michael's birthday party in
a speakeasy burlesque slash cigar bar
anything Kenya no I'll fix it in power
high then that heavy breathing is goose
panting my dog it's not me just like
really just relaxing like weaving then I
went to the o2l house to film some
collabs with Ricky Dillon I'm on my way
to the o2 alehouse to shoot with Ricky
Dillon I'm bringing in some posts to
that house that means so inappropriate
um
what note Ricky's 21 if there's any
teenagers in that house
gross we just played the what's in my
hand challenge and it went it looks like
what's my intern know what's in my hair
yeah chunk right there
oh god I'll fix it you guys I'm a human
being
way flawed youtubers are just like us if
you guys don't know all right they're
going on tour which is very exciting
all right tickets available for tour
Eddie they just went on sale yesterday
for VIP okay but they in general
admission goes until Friday oh and this
video goes up and then this then this
happen well they'll be done we're not
having to feast of fiction to me wrong
one of my favorite people we're making
some candy I think one of my favorite
foods let's go I'm here the feast of
fiction said what cookies yeah can we
say what we made today or is it a
spoiler no you can you can say
everything okay we may pass there was
that goose oh oh yeah where's goose look
at what they made me look at that custom
goose Pez machine
it's just quieter than goose which is
perfect they went to a party at
superwoman
aka Lily Singh's house that she's out
here subletting for a little bit because
she passed two million subscribers
[Music]
it is dude time buta clock what time is
it dude o'clock then I went to Miami for
the nat P convention which was like this
good morning it is or 4500 that was at
that time we're going to Miami for a
convention and they're flying me first
class and I've never flown first class
if someone sleeping on the couch someone
sleeping on decay
[Music]
where are the Kardashians let them know
that's a seagull
[Music]
[Music]
then I get back and they slept a little
bit and then I went to shoot intros and
outros for our camp Takota documentary
oh look we're all here
where Michael gold finds house because
we're recording a distraction some like
it hot we're doing some commentary for
you can see Hannah got a new shirt doing
some commentary for the documentary
portion of the camp Takota movie captain
Cottam compre order etc etc this voice
okay so we just wrapped shooting about
forty intros and outros for the
documentary behind the scenes and now
it's time to eat my favorite time of the
day besides sleeping time and drinking
time and lots of other day and this
classic I'm in the card may my heart
after our epic shoots so long so long so
long and we are going to pick up my car
because it got towed last week yeah
impound then I got to go to the fire
mother's office to sign posters and
t-shirts and the postcard type things
for all the people that supported their
charity a fundraising event they raised
like thirteen thousand dollars for a
School of Rock Rock School the where the
kids learn the instruments and it's so
cool and that happened and it was fun I
meant to find brothers place and we're
signing my music merch there it is yeah
beautiful [ __ ] all of us everyone has
great hair and now I'm so tired and I
have a lot of emails to edit but
I have a lot of emails to edit I don't
know a couple of quick mentions one
there's a brand new episode of goose you
don't have room to make noise right now
cuz you farted so hard right before I
turn this camera on and you know it oh
okay I know you're embarrassed there's a
brand new episode of Graces faces I
touch Megan Liz's stuff and they're just
so adorable they've adorable stuff and -
Hannah Hart my really great wonderful
friend has her cookbook finally
available for you there are links down
below for you to please go pre-order it
and also camp Takota calm as always yeah